non j'ai pas regardé nom jean denis
brogniart merci tirs hostiles
j'avais une petite aventure avec lui
[Applaudissements]
c'est solide mais j'étais quand
l'ambition à terme entre ces deux femmes
dans la même soirée
en plus elle est extraordinaire
sophie taper show denis brogniart oui en
fait j'étais parti à à buenos aires
faire l'émission fear factor ouais avec
pas mal de d'animateur de telle sorte se
terminant sur factor jeudi avant
confinement je dois ou ouais ok mais
cela finit donc la dernière épreuve
c'était c'était avec denis quoi quad en
soirée vous êtes vous êtes restés
ensemble un peu tôt non pas du tout en
fait on est rentré à paris et je me suis
rendu compte qu'ils préféraient le sport
et moi le théâtre est donc voila quoi
sport et on s'en sort et des petits
textos temps en temps mais vous avez
fait l'épreuve des poteaux des poteaux
je suis pas assez longtemps sur le
permis ça oui quand vous avez passé donc
une vie avec denis brogniart et alors
elle va rire ou alors à nous dire que
denis à l'épaule de carrosserie et
j'adore et les polos libre au bout et ça
bah oui c'est un super pote à moi je
l'adoré je sais que tu nous regardes les
sportives à chaque fois qu'on a fait on
a fait qu'au fond de musculation
ensemble et défoncé un bon tennis j'ai
défoncé en course 1 course ils courent
sérieux ah non en fait il n'y est pour
rien mais encore plus après les meufs
apparemment captées qu'après le chrono
après je l'aimais denis et je le redis s
agencent c'est un des mecs que je kiffe
live le temps voilà il est c'est fait et
je peux comprendre qu'on peut être
craqué pour lui les tristes automobiles
étaient en attente ces célibataires
fayat pas bien sur leurs meilleurs pas
du tout et je vais te dire tout ce qui
se passe à pierre factor reste à fear
factor alors que lille a fait la
première mission de paix
mais je la borne mais c'est un amour de
mec